in the Vienna talks Iran is negotiating
with six international powers the five
permanent members of the UN Security
Council and Germany or in short the p5
plus one they fear that Iran is trying
to develop nuclear weapons and in the
eyes of the p5 plus one that could pose
a major threat to world peace one focus
of discussions is nuclear enrichment for
an atomic bomb Iran would need highly
enriched uranium the International
powers want to limit in Richmond to 3.5
% enough for fuel for nuclear power
plants Iran in recent years managed to
enrich uranium to about twenty percent
that set off alarm bells for the p5 plus
one because it's a huge step towards
building nuclear weapons they are
demanding more international checks on
how many centrifuges Iran has available
for enrichment and on Iran's other
nuclear sites for the Iranians that's
going too far Tehran insists it's not
trying to develop atomic weapons and
wants only to harness nuclear power for
energy and medical purposes it's asking
for the international economic sanctions
to be eased they include a ban on
imports of Iranian oil to the European
Union one way forward could be a
combination of fewer sanctions and more
international inspections finding the
right balance could end the deadlock